[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous nouvelle semaine
d'information locale avec le 7-8 journal
sur tv 78 nous sommes le lundi 16
octobre tout de suite les titres de
cette édition mobilisation pour sauver
la ligne 18 maires sénateurs et députés
se réunissent et à la mi journée sur le
site de la future gare de guyancourt
saint quentin en yvelines
ils exigent le maintien du tracé et de
l'arrivée du super métro dès 2024 dans
les yvelines
le maire de versailles françois de
mazières a répondu à nos questions
cette action elle se déroulait samedi
dernier le groupe local de greenpeace
versailles organisé une matinée de
sensibilisation thématique la
vulnérabilité des centrales nucléaires
françaises alors qu'un rapport d'expert
sur le sujet vient de paraître et nous
en parlons avec cécile qu'une un porte
parole de greenpeace versailles et puis
économie le marché de l'immobilier se
porte bien en ile de france + 20 % de
ventes de logements anciens au deuxième
trimestre mais qu'en est-il précisément
dans les yvelines chronique dans ce
journal
c'est une volonté est claire et et
afficher ils veulent la ligne 18 en 2024
et dès 2024 et dans les yvelines ce midi
à près de 200 personnes se sont
rassemblées sur le fut sur le futur site
de la gare à guyancourt à saint quentin
en yvelines
parmi elles élus de l'agglomération
maires sénateurs et députés pour mettre
en avant les conséquences négatives d'un
possible abandon ou report du projet
pour le département et plus
particulièrement pour saint quentin en
yvelines
aurélie rond et nicolas landry mobilisés
pour interpeller le gouvernement élus
des communes de saint quentin en
yvelines du département de la région
députés et sénateurs se sont réunis à
guyancourt sur le site qui pourrait
devenir la gare de la ligne 18 sur
l'agglomération tous présents pour
défendre la mise en oeuvre du projet
ferroviaire avant 2024
aujourd'hui les jeux olympiques c'est un
enjeu aussi fondamentale
on ne peut pas avoir deux discours dire
que nous allons recevoir les jeux
olympiques
appuyez s'appuyer là dessus au niveau du
cio à lima et ensuite derrière nous dire
que abane ont finalement n'aura pas
c'est impossible
pour être assuré par le ministère il
faut nous recevoir rapidement et qu'on
puisse avec les entrepreneurs la
population annoncer la bonne nouvelle
cette bonne nouvelle c'est l'arrivée du
tracé de la ligne 18 dans les yvelines
avant les jeux olympiques avec une gare
située à guyancourt communes qui
accueillent 1200 entreprises et de
nombreux salariés au quotidien ça compte
a emmené ville c'est le deuxième pour
l'économie de l'île de france
on peut pas absolument pas du tout ne
pas avoir de transport structurants et
il faut qu'on se mange nous
effectivement les élus les habitants les
entreprises et les étudiants pour faire
reconnaître que notre territoire est
incontournable un échelon proche des
politiques nationales certains élus
yvelinois ont des ressources importantes
pour peser sur la décision du calendrier
concernant la ligne 18
nous avons sollicité le préfet de région
pour lui demander là dessus des
clarifications pour lui demander une
étude de faisabilité sur le calendrier
qui pourrait demander à société du grand
paris
nous avons un certain nombre d'éléments
naturels mans qui nous laisse penser que
boucler ce projet en 2024 jusqu'à
versailles de cette ligne 18 est tout à
fait faisable
j'irai rappelé les engagements de l'état
au plus haut niveau et j'essaierai de
d'entrer dans des bureaux qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas encore ouverts
je crois que le
les ministères chargés de ce dossier
sont au travail qui vont remettre un
moment donné leur copie au premier
ministre et et qu'à ce moment là une
fois que les hypothèses seront sur la
table le dialogue s'enclenchera avec les
élus locaux pour voir quelle est la
solution la plus efficace et la de celle
qui sera de nature à répondre aux
besoins en marche de cette mobilisation
des élus écologistes de l'agglomération
ont tenu à exprimer leur opposition à ce
projet et à côté de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est la ville de versailles
qui pourraient se retrouver impacté par
l'abandon le possible abandon de
l'arrivée de la ligne 18 versailles
c'est le terminus du projet initial
prévu par la société du grand paris
le maire françois de mazières était
présent ce midi il a été interrogé par
nicolas landry alors en quoi c'est
important cette ligne 18 pour la commune
de versailles
mais je crois qu'elle est importante
pour toutes les communes qui sont sur le
tracé la ligne 18
récemment la ministre des transports est
venu à versailles a confirmé que le
tracé serait bien maintenu le tracé que
l'on connaît pourquoi c'est essentiel
parce que on sait bien qu'aujourd'hui il
ya un projet d'envergure internationale
sur le plateau de saclay et celui ci n'a
pas de sens si l'on occulte sac si la
voie ferrée et c'est aussi un peu
ce qu'on est en train de craindre parce
qu'on on a une confirmation du tracé
mais on n'a absolument aucune indication
sur le calendrier et nous sommes
aujourd'hui rassemblés pour dire qu'il
faut maintenir le calendrier pour que
notamment au cours des jeux olympiques
il y est déjà cet hymne qui fonctionne
c'est possible techniquement c'est
possible on sait que en 2024 au moment
des jeux la ligne peut arriver ici
versailles on sait que ça pour arriver
ensuite en 2025 si là
on y arrive bien en 2024 sur la ville
nouvelle concernant justement vous
l'avez évoqué le calendrier ce qu'est
l'information vous avez aujourd'hui
et bien justement nous n'aurons pas
beaucoup
initialement il avait envisagé 2030
et puis ensuite contenu des progrès qui
avait été fait sur la ligne où nous a
dit c'est possible d'arriver comme je
vous le disais à l'instant ou 2024 en
ville nouvelle 2025 26 sur le terminus
qu'elle a gardée chantier et donc on
dîne surtout n'abandonnons pas ce projet
au contraire puisque maintenant nous
avons été sélectionnés la france a été
sélectionné pour les jeux olympiques
c'est l'occasion ou jamais de maintenir
la pression et de faire le plus
rapidement possible cette ligne donc
nous visons très clairement aujourd'hui
2024 ici 2025 26 à versailles en cas de
remise en cause du projet quelles
peuvent être les moyens de pression les
moyens peut-être juridique pour rappeler
à l'ordre le gouvernement et l'état
j'ai écouté la ligne dans son tracé elle
a déjà fait l'objet d'une enquête
publique donc ce travail très important
est derrière nous et puis ensuite il y
aura tout simplement la volonté des
politiques tous les politiques sont ici
rassemblés pour dire que cette ligne est
essentiel au développement économique
on ne peut pas demander aux communes de
faire des efforts en matière notamment
d'immobilier savez qu'aujourd'hui l'état
nous demande de construire vite beaucoup
on ne peut pas demander cet effort s'il
n'y a pas les moyens de transport
adéquats
qu'est ce qu'on constate qu est-ce que
tous les gens qui vivent
dans la région on constate c car
aujourd'hui un embouteillage permanent
sur les grandes lignes sur les grandes
voies qui desservent la ville nouvelle
et versailles
et donc si on veut construire davantage
il faut qu'on ait résolu le problème des
transports et on ne pourra alors y zone
que si elle aligne 10 me françois de
mazières merci on accueille sur ce
plateau trois invités pour ce journal
maimouna bas bonsoir vous êtes
directrice associée de la bei et le
papillon la crèche citoyenne et
inclusive organise une matinée
d'échangés autour de l'égalité des
chances dès le berceau
c'est mercredi à la cité des métiers de
trappes on en parle tout à l'heure avec
moi également nicolas d'andry bonsoir
bonsoir journalistes pour la rédaction
tv 78 vous nous avez préparé une
chronique sur la situation l'immobilier
dans les yvelines s'est également à
suivre dans ce journal
mais pour commencer je me tourne vers
vous cécile klein bonsoir vous êtes la
porte parole du groupe local de
greenpeace versailles vous organisé
samedi dernier avenue de l'europe à
versailles une action de sensibilisation
au sujet de la sécurité dans les
centrales nucléaires comme dans une
vingtaine de villes en france
votre nge et alerte sur la vulnérabilité
des centrales nucléaires françaises et
belges greenpeace france a mandaté sept
experts internationaux qui ont donc
écrit un rapport sur cette sécurité il
pointe du doigt cette sécurité alors pas
en ce qui concerne directement le coeur
du réacteur mais plutôt les piscines
d'entreposage du combustible
de quoi parle-t-on exactement à quoi
sert veut-elle cc piscine alors les
piscines de refroidissement ou de
désactivation
ce sont les endroits où vous
combustion où va le combustible usagé
après avoir servi à libérer de l'énergie
dans le coeur du réacteur
donc ce combustible qui peut il peut y
en avoir plusieurs centaines de tonnes
dans une seule piscine est encore très
chaud et il faut le refroidir donc avec
l'eau contenue dans la piscine et sato
permet également de d'avoir un rôle de
radio protection vis-à-vis de ce
combustible
le problème c'est que ces piscines sont
très mal protégés et c'est ce sur quoi
alerte
aujourd'hui ce rapport alors pourtant
edf qui gère ces centrales nucléaires
assurent que elles font sur bien
surveillé protégé ses centrales
nucléaires
alors oui c'est ce que dieu edf mais ce
rapport est unanime
ces piscines sont très fragiles le c'est
simplement une couverture de béton qui
fait une trentaine de centimètres
d'épaisseur donc c'est à peu près ce
qu'on trouve dans les à celle dans les
hlm qui ont été construits dans les
années 60 où les hangars agricoles et la
couverture est généralement simplement
en taule
donc c'est très très faible pour le
risque qui est en jeu car s'ils venaient
à si le lot de cette piscine venez à
s'échapper s'il y avait eu un accident
ou une attaque
oui les risques seraient vraiment
important c'est à dire que s'il vous
pouvez parvenait à s'échapper le
combustible qui est brûlant il pourrait
y avoir une explosion d'hydrogène et un
relâchement massif de radioactivité ce
qui bien sûr conduit à des risques
environnementaux et sanitaires majeurs
allant des militants de greenpeace
france ont pénétré sur le site de la
centrale de cattenom en moselle c'était
jeudi dernier et selon les ong
votre ong elle a réussi à tirer des feux
d'artifice sur place edf compte est bien
sûr cette intrusion c'est une action
qu'on peut juger coup de poing mais qui
est nécessaire oui pour pour
sensibiliser sur la question
oui oui c'est nécessaire beaucoup de
gens ignorent
les risques qu'on que des f nous fait
encourir tous les jours les français
mais aussi les habitants des pays
européens frontaliers près desquels les
centrales sont construites cette action
a permis de montrer que vraiment rentré
dans une centrale était possible et le
feu d'artifice a été tiré vraiment au
pied de la piscine de refroidissement
est ce que j'ai oublié de préciser c'est
que c'est l'endroit le plus radioactif
de toute la centrale donc c'est plus
radioactifs encore que le coeur même du
réacteur 2 à 3 fois plus re plus
radioactifs
si on en revient donc du coup à votre
manifestation de samedi ce rassemblement
à versailles tel était le but finalement
c'était aussi de sensibiliser le public
mettre au courant le public de ses
dangers oui tout à fait c'est est de
sensibiliser la population d'alerté de
leur expliquer en quoi tout ceci
constituait parce que effectivement une
piscine de refroidissement
tout le monde ne sait pas ce que c'est
et puis de demander à edf vraiment de
prendre ses dispositions de prendre ses
responsabilités et de bonnes crises et
les piscines c'est à dire de construire
une enceinte de confinement
comme il en existe autour des réacteurs
dont on a fait signer une pétition aux
personnes qui passaient à cet endroit là
à ce moment là et on les a informés
merci c'est celle que d'un d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle vous êtes la porte
parole du groupe local de greenpeace
versailles plus d'infos sur le site
internet de l'omg qui s'affiche pour nos
téléspectateurs et je précise d'ailleurs
que vendredi à versailles à la maison de
quartier porchefontaine sera organisé
une réunion d'information sur les
actions donc 2 à greenpeace
ces images de versailles toujours où se
tenait hier le festival des alternatives
sur le parvis de l'hôtel de ville
7500 visiteurs se sont rendus à cet
événement organisé par le mouvement
alternative à versailles objectif
présenter des alternatives concrètes
pour faire face au changement climatique
au programme 90 stands installés 27
conférences et tables rondes ainsi
qu'une quinzaine de spectacles et
concerts et du nouveau pour vos
démarches dans les yvelines à partir du
6 novembre vous pourrez effectuer vos
procédures de délivrance de la carte
grise et du permis de conduire
directement sur internet
le dispositif était présenté à
versailles la semaine dernière et des
démarches dématérialise
et vous n'aurez plus besoin de vous
déplacer et donc de perdre du temps dans
les files d'attentes de la préfecture
propos recueillis par nicolas landry
alors ce sont les diverses demandes que
peut vouloir faire un particulier qu'il
s'agisse d'un changement d'adressé d'un
changement de situation de son véhicule
une session de son véhicule etc
en matière de permis de conduire bat
simplement l'inscription au permis c'est
la demande de permis une fois qu'on a
réussi les épreuves c'est tout ce qui
est la vie quotidienne je dirais dans le
cadre d'une demande de permis de
conduire ou de cartes grises sont toutes
ces procédures que l'on veut simplifier
pour faire vos démarches en ligne pour
plus d'information sur la procédure et
les pièces à fournir
rendez vous sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et je me
tourne vers vous nicolas d'andry de la
rédaction de tv 78 on parle économie
maintenant avec l'immobilier c'est un
secteur qui est en progression en
ile-de-france les ventes de logements
anciens ont progressé de 20% au deuxième
trimestre cette année par rapport à la
même période en 2016 de bons résultats
alors côté evelyne nicolas comment
évolue le marché l'immobilier
alors le marché plutôt dynamique dans le
département prenons d'abord les
transactions immobilières
les ventes sont en hausse durant le
deuxième trimestre 2010 est près de
trois mille appartements anciens vendus
soit une augmentation de 23% par rapport
au second trimestre 2016 même tendance
pour les maisons anciennes vous le voyez
autour de 2500 au deuxième trimestre
2010 est une hausse de 32% par rapport à
la même période l'année dernière
mathilde très cas d'avis de notaire
associé à guyancourt nous explique les
conditions de cette situation
aujourd'hui je crois qu'un des facteurs
importants c'est quand même les taux les
taux de les taux des prêts qui sont
intéressants les gens investissent
beaucoup en utilisant le profil des taux
intéressants
et puis et puis bal au dynamisme
l'activité qu'il ya autour de chez nous
il ya beaucoup d'entreprises qui
s'installe donc ça fait ça fait venir
pas mal de gens nombre de ventes en
hausse donc dans le département qu'est
ce que ça donne sur l'évolution des prix
alors c'est l'autre signe de cette
reprise sur le marché immobilier
la tendance est aussi à la hausse si on
prend le prix moyen au mètre carré d'un
appartement ancien dans les yvelines
on passe de environ 3500 euros en 2015 à
près de trois mille sept cents en 2017
comme vous le voyez à l'image
concernant les maisons anciennes même
constat le prix moyen a augmenté de 4%
entre 2015 et le deuxième trimestre 2010
est il dépasse aujourd'hui les trois
cent soixante mille euros pour finir
nicholas vous montez sur la situation de
l'immobilier à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
que faut-il noter et bien grégory la
conjoncture est similaire à celle du
département en 2015 près de 2300
transaction immobilière avec un prix
moyen au mètre carré de 3040 euros
maisons et appartements anciens
confondus
à noter que 60 % des acquéreurs sont des
jeunes travailleurs entre 20 ans et 40
ans à ce propos je vous propose
d'écouter l'ancien président de saint
quentin en yvelines qui va parler des
facteurs d'attractivité du territoire
c'était au micro de michael et demi
d'euros il ya quelques semaines nous
avons un endroit où il ya une qualité de
vie exceptionnelle est capable nous
sommes à l'ouest de paris
nous sommes bien desservi aussi et alors
si on se penche plus précisément sur
certaines communes de l'agglomération
on voit que sur cette carte les prix
médian au mètre carré d'un appartement
ancien entre 2011 et le premier semestre
2016 et comme vous le voyez voisins le
bretonneux montigny le bretonneux et
guyancourt ont une médiane supérieur à
3500 euros le mètre carré
on retrouve les prix les plus bas à
trappes la verrière ou encore elancourt
avec des variations de prix en fonction
de deux des quartiers comme vous le
voyez à l'image en fonction des couleurs
chaque quartier à des prix qui varient
même constat pour les maisons anciennes
trappe et la verrière sont les villes
les moins chères
en revanche les prix médians dépasse les
350 mille euros à magny les hameaux
voisins le bretonneux guyancourt ou
encore montigny le bretonneux et
justement concert
dans le marché de montigny le bretonneux
je vous propose d'écouter françois eliès
qui est agent immobilier dans cette
commune sur les quelques dernières
années on a ressenti une petite baisse
de l'immobilier au niveau national avec
certaines régions qui allait jusqu'à -15
avoir moins 20% en termes de baisses de
prix alors que sur montigny la baisse
n'a été que de 3 à 5 points maximum
c'est une bête qui est très très faible
alors pour anvers de la france du fait
de la sensibilité vraiment de saint
quentin et de son pôle économique
alors cette situation locale du marché
immobilier sur saint quentin en yvelines
pourrait se confirmer dans les
prochaines années notamment comme vous
le savez avec l'organisation de
certaines compétitions des jeux
olympiques de 2024 sur notre territoire
merci nicolas pour ces précisions on en
vient à vous maimouna bas je le rappelle
vous êtes la directrice associée de la
bei et le papillon la crèche citoyenne
et inclusive organise une matinée des
changes
autour d'eux les qualités l'égalité des
chances dès le berceau à la cité des
métiers de trappes mercredi parlons de
l'abeille et le papillon d'abord la
société gère deux crèches sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
donc il ya une micro crèche qui
s'appelle les tilleuls qui est à
montigny le bretonneux et un projet ça
va ouvrir en janvier c'est une crèche
interentreprises qui va ouvrir en face
du vélodrome malgré tout à fait donc
c'est une crèche qui doit ouvrir en mars
en 2018 donc on accueillera donc trente
enfants sur ce lieu il aura la
spécificité d'accueillir donc des
salariés des entreprises environnement
environnantes pardon d'accord donc c'est
une crèche interentreprises au même
titre que d'autres crèche inter
entreprises implantées sur le territoire
et nous ouvrons également 5 berceau pour
des familles qui sont inscrits dans un
parcours d'insertion
donc on est en train de travailler avec
la caf pour avoir le label crèche à
vocation d'insertion professionnelle ce
qu'on parle de crèches citoyenne et
inclusive
ça veut dire en fait concrètement alors
citoyenne parce que nous portons un
projet de société donc enfin autre que
l'entreprise donc la bei et le papillon
est entré est ancré sur son territoire
et on milite pour qui et de la mixité
on part du principe que la cohésion
nationale elle travaille et elle se
travaille via la mixité entre autres
c'est en cela qu'on est on est citoyen
et puis même dans notre manière de voir
l'accueil de l'enfant notamment en
travaillant avec des producteurs locaux
en faisant attention ou aux produits
qu'on utilise pour les enfants on est
pleinement ancré dans dans la
citoyenneté et inclusive parce que on
milite encore une fois pour faire en
sorte que chaque enfant quel que soit
son milieu d'appartenance quelle que
soit la catégorie socioprofessionnelle
de ses parents qu'il ait la chance
d'avoir une place en crèche l'accord oui
d'ailleurs vous le dit c'est une
conviction et ce sera là l'objet de
cette rencontre de mercredi c'est
finalement cette place en crèche va
jouer aussi sur le reste de la vie de
l'enfant
c'est dès ce moment là qu'on parle aussi
d'égalité des chances ça va jouer dans
les rapports hommes-femmes dans sa
réussite à l'école c'est aussi ça ce que
vous vouliez mettre en avant tout à fait
l'objectif de cette rencontre qui doit
réunir un certain nombre de deux
personnes sur le territoire donc du
monde de l'insertion du monde de
l'emploi
on va également avoir des partenaires
du dans le domaine sanitaire et social
l'idée c'est vraiment d'apporter donc
cette problématique de la petite enfance
dans le débat sur l'égalité des chances
parce que souvent quand on parle
d'égalité des chances sans générale à
partir de 6 ans - exemple là on parle en
ce moment du dédoublement des classes en
cp il ya des choses qui peuvent se faire
bien bien en amont d'accord que ça soit
avec les enfants ou avec les parents
aussi parce que on ne naît pas par an le
devient donc il ya plein de choses qui
se joue effectivement dès la petite
enfance et on trouve que le on porte pas
le débat assez sûrs d'eux sur la petite
enfance et c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs
mercredi vous avait convié pas mal
d'élus à la rencontre c'est aussi les
sensibiliser à cette question
complètement alors effectivement on a
convié un certain nombre d'élus donc le
délégué du gouvernement et le la
déléguée donc du préfet seront également
là parce que ils ont ils ont cette
responsabilité là aussi d'entendre le
terrain et puis et je pense qu'ils ont
ils ont cette envie aussi
et voilà pour nous c'était important
qu'ils soient associés à ces réflexions
là parce que c'est une matinée de
réflexion et des changes et nos élus ont
aussi leur place lors de cette matinée
là et cette matinée sera animée je le
précise par catherine delcroix qui est
enseignante chercheur en sociologie à
l'université de strasbourg merci
maimouna bas d'avoir été écrit je
m'appelle directrice associée de la bei
et le papillon la crèche citoyenne et
inclusive organise mercredi une journée
une matinée d'échangés autour de
l'égalité des chances dès le berceau
c'est de 9h30 à midi à la cité des
métiers de trappes
infos et inscriptions sur le lien qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran sport c'est
l'une des compétitions les plus
médiatisés au monde diffusée dans 85
pays
la ryder cup vous le savez se tiendra au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'année
prochaine en septembre prochain et un
peu moins d'un an de l'opposition entre
américains et européens les deux
capitaines s'affrontaient pour un match
d'exhibition à guyancourt pour le plus
grand bonheur des enfants présents
reportage de nicolas kirilow liszt pour
le moment les gestes sont amicaux
l'ambiance bon enfant à un an de la rai
or cup à saint quentin en yvelines pour
ce premier duel de capitaine sous le
soleil thomas bjorn et jim furyk diriger
des jeunes de l'équipe de france
une opposition amicale à quatre contre
quatre
mais surtout une expérience
enrichissante pour ces futurs
professionnels expérience ils sont
vraiment la cote et donc c'est génial
quand la pression on connaît pas trop ça
enfin connaît pas autant de pression
du coup savamment court j'avais beaucoup
de stress au début et là ça va beaucoup
dans ce premier match entre américains
et européens les deux équipes ont
terminé à égalité
un résultat loin d'être une déception
surtout pour les enfants ils étaient
plus de 700 à pouvoir approcher les
stars du golf
on a essayé d'avoir des joueurs pros
devant moi d'être ici et ont plaisir à
la ryder cup l'année prochaine honda
style de voir déjà des gens qui auront
sang froid impressionnant
pourquoi bas à la grandeur
déjà
de tous les parcours ses immenses et
surtout de voir des jeunes espoirs
l'événement a permis aussi aux
capitaines de prendre leurs marques sur
le parcours de l'albatros c'est ici que
les 24 joueurs des deux continents
s'opposeront pour la 42e édition de la
ryder cup c'est un parcours de golf
fantastique et d'être le capitaine de
cette ryder cup est vraiment spécial
c'est une journée incroyable avec tous
ses enfants je suis très excité à l'idée
de vivre cette ryder cup à paris la
ryder cup 2018 se tiendra du 25 au 30
septembre prochain près de deux cent
mille visiteurs sont attendus à saint
quentin en yvelines
la compétition reprendra alors tous ses
droits on referme cette page sport et ce
journal avec la cinquième édition de la
ville proviennent dimanche adultes et
enfants ont pu participer à des courses
à pied différentes distances 1 2 5 ou
encore l'épreuve du 10 km un événement
qui a rassemblé 6 130 participants
nicolas landry une matinée sportive
entre frère et soeur mélanie et julien
se sont lancé un challenge participer à
une course de 10 km le plaisir de courir
pour cette fratrie originaire de
villepreux wagnon sera entraîné un petit
peu mais franchement une fois par
semaine à peu près voilà on fait pas
partie d'un club donc c'est plus de
loisirs
j'ai trouvé une source de motivation
aussi avec ma soeur donc on a déjà couru
plusieurs fois ensemble c'est vraiment
très sympa mélanie et julien font partie
des 200 aux coureurs qui ont pris le
départ du 10 km une boucle de 5 km à
parcourir deux fois à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur de la ville
c'est un mix de d'urbain et 2
on va dire de trails donc on a on a des
parcours sur terre donc qui contourne
essentiellement ville preuve avec un
premier tour réalisé en 18 minutes 42
adrien grappille remporte cette course à
la maison en 38 minutes 30 pour le ville
provient cette cinquième participation
aura été la bonne il devance de 30
secondes
emmanuel prix bas c'est mon premier
podium et donc dans ma ville ça fait
vraiment super plaisir
je connais c'est à peu près le parcours
et je savais où faire la différence
de leur côté mélanie et julien ont
terminé la course en une heure et six
minutes hors mode pas s'arrêter là pour
motiver parce que ces tests éprouvera
surtout la deuxième le deuxième tour la
et deux côtes cela qui nous ont bien des
cas c'est l'objectif c'était qu'on
arrive en même temps à la course à
l'arrivée donc voilà on sait attendu
chacun a pendant le trajet pour
l'édition 2018 de la ville proviennent
les organisateurs réfléchissent à une
nouvelle course de 15 km et peut être un
jour proposer un semi marathon c'est la
fin de ce set 8 journal reportage replay
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 on se quitte
avec ces images du soleil et de la
chaleur qui nous ont accompagnés tout le
week-end est également aujourd'hui il
fallait en profiter puisque les
températures vont baisser
progressivement à partir de demain
images signées axel doit bel
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]